>> PEOPLE CAN'T STOP TALKING
ABOUT THE TRAILER FOR THE NEW
BARBIE MOVIE, BUT NOT ALL DOLLS
LIVE IN A DREAM HOUSE.
SOME ARE BIGGER, YOUNGER,
SADDER.
SOME DOLLS ARE AMERICAN GIRLS.
>> HI, KIRSTEN.
>> HI MOLLY.
>> HI SAMANTHA.
>> AND I'M ADDY.
NO ONE SAID HI TO ME.
>> THIS SUMMER, A NEW LIVE
ACTION STORY ABOUT YOUR FAVORITE
HISTORICALLY ACCURATE DOLLS,
EACH WITH THEIR OWN BACK STORY.
>> I'M FROM VICTORIAN TIMES.
I WATCHED MY PARENTS DIE IN A
BOAT.
>> THAT'S OKAY.
MY DADDY'S A PRISONER OF WAR,
AND TRAGICALLY, I HAVE GLASSES.
>> THAT'S OKAY.
MY MAMA IS DEAD.
I DON'T KNOW MY BIRTHDAY BECAUSE
>> THAT'S OKAY.
I'M A RUN AWAY SLAVE.
I DON'T KNOW MY BIRTHDAY BECAUSE
>> LET'S PLAY.
I'M A RUN AWAY SLAVE.
>> YEA!
>> LET'S PLAY.
>> DO THEY HAVE PINK CORVETTES?
>> YEA!
NOPE, BOYFRIENDS, NO WAY.
>> DO THEY HAVE PINK CORVETTES?
DID ALL THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS DIE
NOPE, BOYFRIENDS, NO WAY.
OF VAGUE OLD-TIMEY DISEASES?
DID ALL THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS DIE
ABSOLUTELY.
OF VAGUE OLD-TIMEY DISEASES?
>> FASHION SHOW.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> COME FOR THE FUN, STAY FOR
>> FASHION SHOW.
THE OVERBURDENED PRETEENS
>> COME FOR THE FUN, STAY FOR
WEARING FOUR LAYERS OF COATS AND
THE OVERBURDENED PRETEENS
PANTALOONS.
WEARING FOUR LAYERS OF COATS AND
>> WHAT'S WRONG?
PANTALOONS.
YOU'VE BARELY TOUCHED YOUR TEA.
>> WHAT'S WRONG?
>> THE MEMORY OF MY MAMA IS
YOU'VE BARELY TOUCHED YOUR TEA.
SLIPPING AWAY.
>> THE MEMORY OF MY MAMA IS
LOOK WHAT I CAN DO.
SLIPPING AWAY.
>> THAT'S OKAY.
LOOK WHAT I CAN DO.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S OKAY.
>> AUDIENCES ARE RAVING.
>> YEAH.
WE LOVED IT, SAYS GIRLS WHO
>> AUDIENCES ARE RAVING.
PLAYED SOCCER MAGAZINE.
WE LOVED IT, SAYS GIRLS WHO
THE NEW YORK TIMES WRITES, THESE
PLAYED SOCCER MAGAZINE.
LITTLE GIRLS ARE GOING THROUGH
THE NEW YORK TIMES WRITES, THESE
TOO MUCH.
LITTLE GIRLS ARE GOING THROUGH
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY, GIRLS,
TOO MUCH.
SHOULD WE HAVE A SLEEPOVER
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY, GIRLS,
TONIGHT?
SHOULD WE HAVE A SLEEPOVER
>> YEA.
TONIGHT?
>> WHAT ABOUT YOU, ADDY?
>> YEA.
>> I'M GOOD.
>> WHAT ABOUT YOU, ADDY?
I DON'T TRUST NONE OF Y'ALL.
>> I'M GOOD.
>> WATCH AS THE AMERICAN GIRLS
I DON'T TRUST NONE OF Y'ALL.
TRAVEL ON A JOURNEY FROM
>> WATCH AS THE AMERICAN GIRLS
AMERICAN GIRL LAND TO THE MODERN
TRAVEL ON A JOURNEY FROM
WORLD.
AMERICAN GIRL LAND TO THE MODERN
>> I'M GOING TO STOP WORLD WAR
WORLD.
II.
>> I'M GOING TO STOP WORLD WAR
>> AND I'M GOING TO STOP THE
II.
SPANISH AMERICAN WAR.
>> AND I'M GOING TO STOP THE
>> AND I'M GOING TO END CHOLERA.
SPANISH AMERICAN WAR.
>> THAT'S OKAY.